i was a big darth park fan um during
like the discovery album actually and
like i'm think i'm thinking back and a
lot of my favorite songs or a lot of my
favorite music
have visuals to accompany them like do
you guys do you guys okay when you guys
listen to a song do you guys like do you
guys imagine like a music video in your
head or anything sometimes yeah it
depends on the song for me yeah yeah
okay like what i'm doing yeah like for
me like if if i can't i can't connect to
a song unless i can imagine some kind of
story or some kind of visuals to
accompany that song and i feel like i
have such a random song i have such a
random music taste because
to to me like i don't really listen to
lyrics but if a song
emotes an emotion or a visual image in
my head then that's when i get really
emotionally connected to a song right
and to me that how i discovered daft
punk was i discovered it through
interstellar five five five five right
which was a [ __ ] amazing movie and
it's also one of it's also one of the
few albums i have listened to all the
way through based purely
from that movie yeah and from then on
from watching that movie and seeing the
story that they crafted from that movie
every darth punk song i listen to i have
such cool visuals that go along
that that's why i became like such a
massive darth punk fan how did that even
happen that anime
was it literally just the guy i listened
to it was like holy [ __ ] i gotta make it
gotta make an anime to go with this i
think yeah i i don't know exactly but i
think matsumoto deji was like a fan of
daft punk and then they just like worked
something out and then because it's it's
so good i guess
i would like to know like uh what kind
of
what kind of like [ __ ]
what do i have to do to get
mathematician to make a music yeah how
did that connection happen
this was before anime was even close to
big you know
this was like underground as [ __ ] so
yeah do you have a do you have a
favorite song from the album
mine always changes quite often france
it's hard uh from death punk it's
probably harder better faster stronger
that's good um yeah that's good i mean
for me for me it's like i know it's the
vanilla pig but like one more time will
always be one more time one more time
one more time with digital
digital love is [ __ ] incredible
yeah um and like i think the reason i
picked harder better faster stronger was
because i remember when i first started
getting to amvs and everyone everyone
tried to make linkin park amvs i did
nothing but just make darpan kmvs that
was that was me man that was like
everybody
the rest of youtube went through the
rest of [ __ ] youtube went through a
linkin park face i was here just like it
was like the entire discovery channel in
anime form aside from like not even the
movie but just like in naruto clips and
then when you heard the the kanye west
remix
like oh my god
i think that's that i heard that before
i heard the
original death punk i discovered kanye
through that song huh i was like what
who was that
who's this guy rapping over a daft punk
song and then this is so good
like at first i hated that song because
i'm just like why would you ruin harder
better faster strength and then like the
more i listen to it the more i'm like
all right let's [ __ ] this [ __ ] slap
yeah this [ __ ] slap kanye all right
you're you're a crazy [ __ ] but
he's gonna get big
i can feel it
this guy's gonna do stuff i think it's
gonna be quite normal and arctic monkeys
obviously british obviously i mean i
again i mean i've already talked about
my indie phase i've kind of just it
wasn't just arctic monkeys it was like
everyone born around
are
generation-ish
yeah loves artichokes because if i would
have to say if i would have to say what
my
what influences i took when
uh when i was in my band right it was
bands like arctic monkeys
uh the klaxons strokes uh who else was
like big at the time razor lights
um also like red hot chili peppers and
foo fighters as well just like just like
any any in australia around that time
white stripes was massive oh white
stripes as well
i love the white stripes so yeah i mean
that that that slot is just there for
just for just mid-2000s
british check um your pillows and then i
have the pillows well i i put the
pillows there because i did go through a
phase where there was a lot of anime
music
back then i didn't like i didn't look up
the bands behind the anime music it was
it was just anime music you know what i
mean and my apple thing was tv size
bracket
a lot of one minute 30 songs yeah and i
remember fuli [ __ ] was like the first
entire ost that i've thought i took i
took this entire ost because every song
in the fulikuri osd because it was
basically just the pillows album right
yeah it was just an album of the pillows
it was the first time where i took an
entire anime ast and put it on my mp3
player which wasn't even an ipod uh it
was like this like an actual like mp3
yeah yeah this it was it was like a
knock-off cheap-ass like chinese mp3
player that i can't even remember the
brand uh because it doesn't exist yeah
probably doesn't exist anymore uh
because i couldn't afford a proper ipod
or proper like branded mp3 player i had
one that was like kind of like shaped
like a like a long pill it was like a
blue pill yeah so then you could put
like an aux cord and it was like a tiny
tiny screen and the name of the song
would like scroll across yeah oh
good times yeah kids will never
understand
and and and i mean like the pillow is
kind of it is again kind of just like
japanese but also has had like i was
this close to putting the pillows on
mine but i didn't yeah
and and like
again like the reason i really loved uh
that soundtrack is because flcl is kind
of just like an amv but yeah just just
just in just in six episodes
season good
it's good but nowhere near us it's not
as good as i've never watched it has it
has its moments you gotta watch the
first one but like to me like ninety
percent of why i love hoodie so much was
because of the pillows oh yeah um and
the visuals were kind of it was kind of
like watching interstellar five five
five again well so if you like the music
you'll like the anime oh yeah what if
you're not into the music and you're
like
it's gonna be hard to not be into the
music yeah yeah yeah i mean it kind of
it kind of sets the tone of the entire
show that makes sense there's a reason
why it's like one of the most like
famous anime
yeah people never shut up about fully
cool yeah why it's so amazing yeah yeah
but like it's it's it's like it's it's
like moments like this where i was
afraid whenever people were just like yo
well let's
pass yours call let's see what your
music taste is and i'm just like [ __ ]
man what how am i going to explain yeah
like tv size narrator opening [ __ ] like
what is that what is that yeah but at
least it was like you know like hard you
know custom dry like j-rock right like i
was listening to like lucky star opening
on my mp4 i was like that's even harder
to explain it's like yeah past the orcs
i'm like i don't think you want the orcs
man like
i i definitely listened to too much
hannah montana at one point
more than i'd care to admit
i was like obsessed with hannah montana
i don't know why so much so that one of
the first books i ever read was miley
cyrus's autobiography are you serious
i'm not kidding i'm not kidding i wish
that was a joke i wish that was those
strings
fan for some reason i was obsessed with
the disney channel when i was like 12 or
13. that makes sense i think i was sold
on the dream that you can do whatever
you wanted to do yeah yeah i realized
that no it's not how it works and then
you still have miley turned out right
yeah
there's just selena gomez woman's
much better switch gears
much better i'm done with it what do you
mean i don't know
i don't know why i just liked it and
also i i like the music for some reason
i think weird it's weird how when you're
12 and 13 you're just [ __ ] idiot i
was i was more obsessed with hillary
dolph
hillary yeah
yeah miley didn't really click for me
hillary i was like yeah
i can get behind this
[Music]
i don't know why
i feel like everyone has that one thing
that they've they've like they've shoved
down in subconsciously depressed and
they're like i never like this if you
say if you say i did i did not it's so
inexplainable now that i think about it
i was like why why i don't like hillary
doc i cannot explain to you why was she
like hot to me i don't know
i think i like the escapism that it
offered yeah yeah that could be a team
yeah copium something
that's all of your old copies what's
wrong with me and i'm this jaded british
man who likes beans on toast but back
then i had dreams and stuff
there's a channel yeah what the [ __ ]
happened to you
anyway anime does that he does that [ __ ]
destroys dreams yeah i mean so that is
that is my three by three i don't know
if that's like random as [ __ ] um it
makes sense i mean like i
i feel like i've talked more behind the
stories of the stories of uh i just want
to hear more about you being in a band
now like how am i supposed to live
stories about living in the band
oh my god who's gonna be next oh my god
it's it's the joey no one end of episode
upside down sorry hill let's put jerry's
on